when an English girl becomes a
celebrated beauty she sometimes ends up
on canvas in the national gallery and
when she has talent as well as beauty
she usually ends up on film Hollywood
we're all very happy that this was the
pattern in the case of Miss Deborah Carr
who will present the awards for writing
achievement miss Carr
perhaps it might be well never to point
out to you as an English woman that the
writer of one British film was not in
the running the fellow whom sat down
every line of Hamlet because it's not
living no no no it's because he wrote
for another medium our awards are only
for work done directly for the screen
that seems to as we say over here make
sense I'm terribly glance how much
should I say done I would like to think
mr. Shakespeare of the globe would be
interested in the work his fellow
craftsmen are turning out for this
unimaginable in twork the following
pictures were nominated for the Best
Screenplay a Foreign Affair paramount
screenplay by Charles breathless Billy
Wilder and Richard L green Johnny
Belinda Warner Brothers screenplay by
earn guard van keulen Allan Vincent the
search presents film metro-goldwyn-mayer
Swiss screenplay by Richard Schweitzer
and David Wechsler the Snakepit
20th Century Fox screenplay by Frank
Patterson millon brand treasure of
Sierra Madre Warner Brothers screenplay
by John Huston John Huston for treasure
the Award for Best Motion Picture story
covers only stories written for the
screen not previously published or
produced in any other medium the award
goes to the author or authors of the
story the following were nominated for
the Best Motion Picture story
the Louisiana story Robert Flaherty
lopat films presentation story by
Francis and Robert Flaherty the Naked
City Marc Hellinger productions
Universal international story by Marvin
Wald
red river Monterey productions United
Artists story by boredom chase the Red
Shoes J Arthur rank arches Eagle Eye and
British story by Emeric Pressburger the
search presents films
metro-goldwyn-mayer swiss story by
Richard Schweitzer and David Wechsler
Richard Schweitzer and David bechler for
the search
thank you very much miss car